навчання в умовах війни через воєнні дії
міноосвіти рекомендувало закладам
змінити структуру навчального року
перший семестр має тривати З 1 вересня
до 1 грудня А другий з 15 лютого по 30
червня у пріоритеті денна форма навчання
але адміністрація може запровадити
дистанційну або змішану форми перед
початком занять студенти пройдуть
інструктаж з безпеки де дізнаються як
реагувати на сигнал повітряної тривоги
як діяти у разі початку воєнних дій або
загрози терористичного акту та як
безпечно дістатися до укриття також для
студентів проведуть уроки і тренування з
безпеки більше про вступну кампанію
шукай на сайті мон у розділі
професійно-технічна освіта а також на
сторінках Міністерства у соціальних
мережах приклади квітів вступай до
профтеху
[музика]